been a change for uh
david ross he's got david bodie at third
base just
seconds ago we were told that chris
bryant was a scratch two men on nobody
out here's javier baez two and two and a
curve missed outside but he gets a
strike three call it was never in the
strike zone oh wow bias rung up on
strikes and dubai's credit no argument
went back to the cubs dugout one away
kyle schwarber the batter no score
bottom of the first
hard hit but this
should be
and is an inning ending double play
and so mitch keller puts the first two
men on and he gets out of it so that's
one away and here is nico horner to try
to drive in the run
jammed him rolled to short
and we're gonna have out number two
newman to murphy take that out any day
of the week no score third inning here's
ian happ
pretty well hit deep to center dyson
will watch it go
home
ian half makes it one to nothing
third long ball of a young season for mr
ian half came on a one-two breaking ball
hey look at that rainbow
maybe that's a positive sign
that's beautiful
so
deep center this baby will go
[Applause]
[Music]
his third of the year
this ball
was absolutely
obliterated
barely had time to enjoy the rainbow
here's the 1-0 and it bounces in the
dirt two balls and no strikes he's
calling out a trainer oh no that one did
look funny keller is going to have to
leave
deep short bias loves that to show off
the arm
javier made the long reach backhanded
planted his feet very quickly and made a
strong throw to first
and he's old for two tonight
seven strikeouts for chatwood
career high is 11 strikeouts he did that
against the brewers back in 13. swing
and a miss contreras will
rizzo that's nine
for chatwood
and what's going on here ferraris needs
a new bit
man this is like the olympic torch
watching chadwick here you're starting
to think
will he strike him out but what will he
strike him out with
wow
how about a cutter yeah why not
so that's ten strikeouts through five
innings he's now walked horner and the
bases are loaded in 2-0 cubs have the
bases loaded body weights the pitch and
a swing and a fly ball out to center
routine for dyson
and he'll make the catch and the inning
comes to an end a hit three left seventh
on its way cubs two pirates nothing
tyler chatwood
outstanding
as he makes his second start of the year
his longest streak as a cub
14 in a row swinging a fly ball to left
routine for schwarber virtually in his
tracks makes the catch
newman holds it first one down
swaying in a miss that's 11. reynolds
has walked and struck out and
it is oppo it's a single will take it
two on with two outs he's gotten polanco
looking and swinging
chadwood delivers ball four he spiked
the cutter in the dirt jeremy jeffress
he will face phillip evans with the
bases loaded two ounce cubs leading
two-nothing top of the seventh inning
a bouncer handled by bodhi throw to
first jeffress gets out of it they leave
him loaded
time for the seventh inning stretch
ground ball rizzo will smother jeffress
to first one away
oh rizzo
what a play
that ball was ticketed for the right
field corner and rizzo grabbed it two
down over the batter cubs lead two
nothing
a drive to deep left field way
back then
gone
four
nothing in the eighth
and the other way with authority
well he's really swinging it well
strong like bull
this delivers left-hander kyle ryan
pitching change cubs if they win this
one it'll be three series and three
series wins
to start the season the pitch
and he cracks that ball out to right and
deep hayward turns around and there it
goes a home run
colin moran hits his fifth home run of
the year
and the pirates get two back it's four
to two they've given up three runs they
had four to play with can the pirates
get one more ball to short could do it
baez goes to second cubs win by a score
of four to three